when they get what they want they might
think oh you know what i like that i
want that again
i'm going to keep lying
they're going to get that again
so now the female is sitting there
thinking oh this guy's amazing
but it's all based on a lie
i've i found more that get what girls
will do is the guy will be broad and say
oh i'm i'm looking you know he might not
say specifically what he's looking for
but if you say are you looking for a
relationship
specifically like they usually tell you
the truth yeah yes or no like they it's
not they might say no i'm not cool no
and i don't think they do
i think there's a good twenty percent of
people that lie
the right guys the right guys a scumbag
will no i don't want to say that's
nothing about a guy that doesn't get a
lot of girls will do i don't think it's
just that dog or a guy that's not
confident in himself we'll tell you what
you want to hear but a guy that knows
what he wants to exactly so you know it
is i feel like guys like because it's so
easy a guy that knows what he wants will
just tell you like
the kind of guy i am if i wasn't with my
girl knows this as well
i don't beat around the bush if i'm
trying to [ __ ] a girl i'll just let you
know straight up listen i'm trying to
hit what are you saying and if it's not
that and
it's not just a random girl either it's
a girl that i would have interacted with
before obviously you don't just go to a
random girl so i'm trying to hit what
you're saying but you'll get hit yeah
this is what i'm saying
more time you have to just be open and
just i don't want to waste less time i
wouldn't waste no one's time i wouldn't
want someone wasting my time either so
if that's the direction i'm trying to go
with that girl i'll let it know i'll let
it be known from the start i'm not
trying to waste my time or your time
like where are we going with this that's
a good thing but
vice versa if i'm looking for a
relationship would be the same thing as
well yeah i'll let you know from the job
right not everyone is like this oh yeah
that way though
okay i'm curious guys point of view do
you feel like most girls when they pick
a toxic guy they know from the jump he's
trouble yeah like like maybe maybe he
might lie but like they ca girls can
smell other girls
around him yeah i won't say necessarily
other girls yeah but it's like it's like
i feel like
i feel like let's be real here like
people know
to an extent you should know when you're
being lied to it depends for example
like a guy can say i love you
this guy don't take you on dates you
don't give you flowers you don't do this
you should kind of know you're not ready
there's no act like you can say whatever
words he wants yeah and but let's be
real he's not showing it so it's like so
i feel like i get that you know what
cause i've got mandom yet and i speak to
them and i'm like
like me personally i've never me i've
only been into relationships so
yeah i don't do relationships unless i
really want to dedicate my time and
stuff but i've asked my guys and i said
like why do you like to
i'm seeing you chat to this girl you
you're misleading the wider and he's
like bro
she wants to hear this yeah so sometimes
it's like i'll be sometimes you want to
hear these lies because it's like girls
will say that sometimes i don't want to
sleep with someone unless i'm in a
relationship so you don't feel like a
thought whatever word but then it's like
this is a fake relationship this is just
for your peace of mind so you want to
hear these lies so you can tell yourself
i was in that relationship i know it too
i feel like sometimes girls say that
though just for the sake of saying it
like you're saying we want to hear
certain things and obviously if your
behavior doesn't reflect that as in like
you were saying you know you're not
taken out you're not showing off you
haven't met any friends or anything like
that like we do the same thing
well
some women do i'm one of those women but
to be honest from the get-go
is the best thing
everyone does need a little ego boost
and also we all do want to be charmed a
little bit like you said if you just
walked up to someone and said i'm just
trying to hit that
yeah
it might work but very rarely yeah
you know what i mean it's not everyone
yeah so i think people might not like it
but i think they'll respect it yeah well
the honesty
i i feel like honesty is the best policy
i'm just saying i feel like obviously
people lie because
sometimes people want to hear like i
said some people generally one exactly
is so much less be real it is easier to
lie at times but then it's like if
you're a good person that's why you
don't like you know what i mean because
you like you feel morally wrong but is
it easier to lie yes it definitely is
that's why some people just like you
know she knows i don't like her
but let me lie to her
it's easier to tell the truth i got a
question definitely though for you
you know the guy that sorry
you know the guy that um you're in a
situation with did he lie to you about
where you're at
yeah
and when at what point did you figure
out it was a lie
you don't have to you don't have to
answer if you don't want no i'm going to
be very honest because i do feel like
we all have to take accountability for
our own actions do you see what i mean
yeah um
quite early on probably six months in
okay and how long has it been
two years all right
and you still like maddie in love or not
maddie i don't know like you still
got feelings for him
yeah
that's honest
i appreciate that yeah
what makes you stay you just feel like
you can't walk away
um
or do you do you think at some point
he'll change his mind
i think i did think that
i definitely think i was maybe living in
a bit of hope
maybe there's like a bit of a charac
being dangled in front of me
you know when i was realizing or when i
was questioning certain things
and
i think i'm probably in a better place
now because i'm quite aware of what the
situation is
and i'm quite ready to just kind of you
know like move forward which is great
um
i can't knock him completely because i
feel like there was a lot of things he
showed me you know how we're talking
about actions speak louder than words um
and i think some women will
ignore that
because it's not what they want to see
it's not what they want to feel
you know they want to believe like nah
this guy's right for them but in reality
if someone is showing you something
you've really got to take that in
so um how old did you say you are 33 33
do you ever worry like do you want a
family and like kids and stuff i've got
a son okay he's 14. okay um
i would want to have
another child however i do feel like i'm
on a
short time frame now yeah well because i
would just think um
because i i've like broken up with
people or like ended things because
i don't want to waste time and because
you only have so much youth you know do
you ever worry you can't find someone
else because you're still emotionally
invested in this guy absolutely
yeah i feel like i've probably done that
for quite a while yeah
so i definitely think that um
i call it blocking my blessings
you know
if you're emotionally invested in
someone else then you might miss
someone amazing because
you're mentally still there do you know
what i mean
um
yeah i think it's just i think women
generally speaking i think there's a lot
of us that do need to
really take in
what's put in front of us
so and this is a common like complaint i
hear from guys because like they value
you know purity and they value youth
right and so like a common complaint is
okay you passed over me in your 20s in
your early 30s
and now you're expecting me to come in
at 35 and deal with all the damage that
the previous guys have done for the past
decade
and it's it's funny because everyone's
like nodding they're like yeah that
happens